okay I want to talk today about
something called the narcissism of small
differences or the narcissism of minor
differences as it's sometimes known and
this would the announcement that Bernie
Sanders is running he's now in the
twenty twenty primary it's a really
important conversation for the left to
have and it's an important conversation
because of some of the factions that are
developing on the left in short terms
and sort of like the briefest way to
define this the narcissism of small
differences is when the small
differences that separate certain people
are overstated to such a degree that
they appear to be massive differences
and cause conflict when there really
doesn't need to be any conflict this
goes back to the 1920s and Freud
actually but there's lots of different
interpretations as to where this
originally comes from but the idea is we
become narcissistic about our own views
on small differences with other people
why this exists is open to some
interpretation there's one idea more
from Freud that there's a kind of
satisfaction to humans of an inclination
to aggression a mild inclination to
aggression and if it seems like we agree
on 95% of stuff of political issues for
example something in us becomes
satisfied when we find something we can
be aggressive about or hostile about
with other people so we focus
disproportionately on the 5% difference
rather than the 95% agreement or
similarity another idea about where the
narcissism of small differences comes
from is that there's just a kind of
general desire to be different and so
when we see that we have a lot in common
with someone else we have a resistance
to feeling that we're just like them so
we will find small differences to argue
about so that we feel unique Christopher
Hitchens had many interesting
commentaries that sort of circled around
this idea the reason that this matters
is that when you become consumed by
minor differences
things start to become exclusionary I'm
separate from those who have this minor
disagreement with me and we start to
focus on the trivial and kind of miss
the forest for the trees to use a
metaphor so let's now look starting with
the 2020 primary at how this is starting
to manifest already it's a primary right
so we've got to make a choice between
the options we do have some duty to
figure out what are the differences
between the candidates and there are
important differences but then there's
also minor differences that are not
practically speaking super-important
let's look for example at Elizabeth
Warren and Bernie Sanders on policy
positions Bernie and Elizabeth Warren
are very very similar in terms of where
they've ended up now I've pointed out to
you Elizabeth Warren comes from the
center more and has been pulled to the
left bernie comes from more of a left
socialism perspective and has been
pulled towards pragmatism he and
Elizabeth Warren have basically ended up
in the same place on most policies not
on all great we don't have to go crazy
arguing about Warren versus Bernie in
the destructive way that I'm already
starting to see friends do on Facebook
they're two of the leftmost candidates
they are arguably the two left most
members of the United States Senate if
either of them won the primary I would
gladly vote for either let's not allow
narcissism over small differences to
cloud that they're not only obviously
better than Donald Trump but they're
mostly better than a lot of the other
Democratic candidates as well in
geopolitics we have lots of examples of
the narcissism of small differences the
partition of India and Pakistan is an
example that maybe is less well known
but a good example let's I mean I'll
take this head-on let's look at an
example that's related to me there are
people on the Left who disagree with me
about the israeli-palestinian conflict
let's explore this like adults for a
second since I know many of you are
probably already thinking about that
how significant are our differences
really in practice I would imagine that
I and most of my audience agrees that
the current israeli-palestinian status
quo is unacceptable
I imagine that we mostly agree that
Benjamin Netanyahu is not going to be an
arbiter of peace in the Middle East I
think we all basically agree that the
Palestinian people are being treated
like crap as a result of what's going on
and we need the most direct path to
ending that that we can possibly find
I would assume my audience and I mostly
agree that the blockade on Gaza has to
be lifted as a top priority of whatever
agreement is made as soon as an
agreement as possible on settlements I
think my audience mostly agrees with me
that new settlements must stop and as
many as reasonably possible are going to
have to be dismantled as part of an
eventual long term peace deal where
might we disagree I've said that I think
there are probably some settlements that
might have to be land swapped in an
eventual agreement maybe some people in
the audience disagree with me about that
but it's a relatively minor difference
my audience and I are I believe on the
same page in opposition of moving the
American Embassy in Israel from Tel Aviv
to Jerusalem so in the end the
differences are relatively minor but
there is a tendency to focus on those
differences overstate them and end up
losing all possibility of sensible
conversation on that basis so what does
this mean for 2020 what does this mean
for the left going forward what this I
think means what I think the takeaway
has to be is let's understand that in
general the narcissism of small
differences is something that can be
destructive let's further our
understanding even in just thinking back
to the interview that I just did that
social media makes this way worse
because it leads to a situation where
oftentimes people are interacting on
social media
only on the basis of the small
disagreements you're not likely to tweet
back and forth with people or to simply
comment on YouTube about how you agree
about ninety-five percent on about 95
percent of issues with someone else
that's on YouTube or on Twitter you're
likely to engage only on those small
differences and that just exacerbates
the problem and the last thing I will
say is that as important as it is not to
fall into the trap of the narcissism of
small differences let's not mistake real
differences as small right so one
example Trump versus Hillary as we are
now seeing with the embarrassment of the
US on the world stage the Supreme Court
decisions that Donald Trump has made and
everything else
some people incorrectly assess the
difference between Trump and Hillary as
small in 2016 that's also a danger we
have to recognize serious differences
where they exist look forward to hearing
from you about this